this is all planned out this is being
planned from the very top
we actually saw a video from louisville
of a u-haul truck
being pulled up and antifa slash blm
slash general leftist insurrectionists
passing out pre-made signs passing out
armor
passing out tools that these riders can
use
to attack cops and to attack civilians
that they don't like
so here they come all these guys now
they're in uniforms by the way
the antifa guys with some except maybe
one or two exceptions they're all
wearing black
all black and they're taking out these
sons abolish
the police abolition
now meaning abolition of our criminal
justice system
of our law enforcement system which what
does that mean
i get it look everybody hates the cops
when they get pulled over right
everybody hates the cops when they get a
parking ticket
everybody is really upset at our law
enforcement system
sometimes and yet we're very grateful to
the cops into our law enforcement system
because they they allow us to
have our property protected to allow our
have our lives protected to
exist in the system that is so wonderful
attacks on law enforcement
are seductive because sometimes everyone
gets irritated at the cops
but what they are really is a symbol for
an attack on our law
on our nation itself
the cops the law enforcement are the
symbol
of the nation of laws that we have
and so they attack the cops somebody's
paying for these u-holes somebody's
somebody's paying to for these people to
communicate
somebody is organizing them
this group is antifa they are
working in tandem over the past six
months
with blm and a validly marxist
organization
we are told that antifa does not exist
that's what the mainstream left has told
us they don't exist right
well if they don't exist if it's just a
little local phenomena pops up in
portland then how come it pops up in
louisville if it pops up in louisville
and this is a a louisville issue right
this issue of the brianna taylor case
why were there riots yesterday in
washington dc
as well and if there's not an
organization called antifa
how come they wave a flag cnn cnn
actually had to admit this
and they had been pushing this whole
thing antifa is not real forget about
antifa
well finally during the the mayhem in dc
last night cnn admits
that that these people are organized and
they're organized
under the same banner there are
restaurants and bars and apartments
chanting all sorts of things
anti-gentrification slogans
anti-police slogans some have been
banging on on street signs with batons
and bats
fireworks have been have been fired off
we've seen graffiti sprayed
on a variety of buildings and even seen
an antifa flag
clearly being flown and waved at the
front of the march
but i thought they didn't exist how do
they have a flag if they're not a real
organization how come they have uniforms
and equipment
and a flag and funding and they're in
multiple cities they're all over the
country because of course they do exist
so cnn had to change its tune on this
and cnn actually
showed the flag later on in the clip you
can actually see it
in the the coverage and tifa walks right
by the camera
waving their flag i want to go to cnn's
alex marquardt
in washington where protesters have darn
lemon
yeah don you know protesters took to the
streets uh
in huge numbers in the wake of george
floyd's death and they are back out in
the streets of washington tonight
uh this is the protest out here at 11
p.m
eastern time uh this group gathered
around four hours ago
they've been on the march now for the
past two leaving from the white house
and really doing a big loop around
washington dc
anti-fed just these protesters at least
they weren't burning down any buildings
in that particular shot so he could
almost credibly call them protesters and
you see don lemon cutting to it
don lemon who previously
defended antifa this is a little bit of
a change in tune
for cnn not totally because they're not
totally condemning them here
but don lemon went on tv went on cnn
and defended this antifa organization
which targets
civilians to achieve political ends do
you know do you know what that's called
that's terrorism that's the base
definition of terrorism antifa which
tears down
property which burns down buildings
which attacks cops
which tries to kill civilians which
sometimes succeeds at killing civilians
don lemon said hey not every
organization is perfect
it says it right in the name antifa
anti-fascism which is what they were
there
fighting listen there's you know no
organization is perfect there was some
violence
um no one condones the violence but
there are different reasons for antifa
and for these neo-nazis uh to be their
one racist fascists
the other group fighting racist fascists
there is a
fascist there's a distinction there hey
look antifa they're really good they're
anti-fascist okay yes sometimes they
kill civilians that's
i guess that's that's not good you know
but no one's perfect and uh
look nobody condones violence but also
antifa is really good that was the
that was the compliment sandwich that
don lemon prepared for antifa right
big compliment minor criticism big
compliment
but let's zoom in on that minor
criticism no organization's perfect i
guess that's true
yeah okay they're a little violent yup
they're more than a little violent
no one condones violence well that's not
true
the left is condoning violence not
radicals even not
extremists but
leftists on don lemon's own
network i mean he in his compliments is
tacitly condoning the violence
but even his ostensibly more moderate
counterpart
chris cuomo is explicitly
condoning the violence just a few weeks
ago
chris cuomo goes on tv to defend the
riots and he says wait a second
since when do protests have to be
peaceful and please
show me where it says that protests are
supposed to be polite
and peaceful the first amendment that's
where it says that you have a right to
peaceably assemble
not a right to burn down cities but just
more evidence that
well well the left is going to tell you
as the cities burn and their poll
numbers go down so they have to start
slightly going after antifa and they say
look no one condones violence
they have been condoning violence this
entire time and they've been encouraging
it the entire time
and now they're going to try to lie to
you and tell you that they haven't and
they're going to tell you that orange
man bad because he doesn't want a
peaceful transfer of power
the left is engaging in political
violence
to steal political power away from the
duly elected president
and they've been doing it for six months
at least
i don't ever want to hear that word come
out of their mouth again
peace peaceful they've lost their
privileges to use that word they've lost
their privileges to
lecture me on the peaceful transfer of
power
when you use violence and you try to
steal an election i'm done there's no
why are we even having this conversation
with them anymore
next time some reporter asks trump that
question he shouldn't even give it he
should just move on
move on to the next reporter who's going
to ask another stupid question
and i actually don't even mean just to
attack the mainstream media here they
are just
tools pushing this violence the
intellectual heft
pushing this violence goes much deeper
goes into the heart of academia so you
might be asking okay
there's this totally fine grand jury
decision that comes out in the brianna
taylor case which has been completely
misrepresented by the mainstream media
and that's fine that's in louisville
why are there riots in dc well okay i'll
do you one more
why is the president of ohio state
university
weighing in on the alleged injustice of
a case
that she knows nothing about that's
exactly what happened when ohio state
president christina
johnson said more or less in a kind of
boring academic but nonetheless radical
way
no justice no peace briana taylor
deserves justice
and this does not feel like justice we
cannot accept what has happened in
louisville
we grieve the tragic and senseless loss
of brianna taylor
a daughter a friend a niece
a loved one who is unarmed and asleep
the breakdown in the justice system and
the killings of unarmed black and brown
people in our country
has become all too familiar tragically
this isn't going to stop until we create
an anti-racist world
we must come together to draw strength
from each other and advance our
collective vision
for a better world where we one day have
justice for all
there is much work to be done that's so
creepy
she's talking like a brainwashed person
it's funny because she's leading one of
the institutions that does the
brainwashing
but she's just some administrative hack
right i mean she's just the
president of the university used to be
that presidents of the university were
serious academics this woman i don't
think so
but she just repeats the talking points
and notice that she goes this will never
go away
we can never have justice until we have
an anti-racist
world anti-racist now in that phrase
nobody
would object to that right but
anti-racist obviously doesn't mean
anti-racist it means the opposite of
that it means a very racist world
and beyond that a very violent world a
very unjust world
but they use the term anti-racist in the
same way that antifa uses the term
anti-fascist
you got antifa you got antera anti-rise
the anti-racists
but it doesn't mean anti-racist at all
both of those things antifa and antera
very very bad because what they mean is
a total racial bigotry
bigotry of other sorts as well and
ultimately what it boils down to is
injustice
ruled by a mob that has a wicked evil
vision of the good
ruled by a mob that is a validly
anarchistic that is
sometimes a validly marxist in the case
of blm
ruled by very very very bad people
who want to tear down everything good
that we cherish in the world you know
marx who is sort of the big mack daddy
godfather of all of these movements
marx famously called for we said it
yesterday on the show the ruthless
criticism of all that exists
his conception of the good that he's
trying to force on society
is just the opposite of what we've all
thought the good is his conception of
human nature totally the opposite of
what we thought
human nature was his conception of
justice totally the opposite of actual
justice
that's what these guys are pushing
that's why it matters when you know you
say oh who cares some
even when you say there's some riot in
some cities okay why do i why do i care
doesn't affect me it doesn't it does
because the intellectual poison of this
movement
is spreading throughout the entire
country and it threatens to tear the
whole thing down
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you